Guten Tag, mein Name ist Sumera Firat, ich bin auf dieser Station als Assister der Sinteti und würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen. Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, natürlich, ich habe doch jemanden nach mir gucken.
Wenn Sie Fragen haben oder etwas nicht verstehen, bitte sagen Sie mir Bescheid.
Wenn Sie mir über Ihre aktuellen Beschwerden erzählen, würde ich Ihnen gerne ein paar Alkamaein-Fragen stellen.
Wie heißen Sie das?
Ich heiße Paul Schuster.
Paul Schuster.
Bitte könnten Sie Ihren Vornamen und Nachnamen langsam und deutlich bestabieren.
Ja, der Vorname ist ganz kurz P-A-U-L.
Ja.
Und der Familienname ist Schuster, S-C-H-U-S-T-E-R.
Um Sie zu sein, bestabiere ich noch einmal. Ihr Vorname lautet P-A-U-L.
U, nicht U, U, Paul.
U wie U-Bahn.
Ja, genau, U wie U-Bahn.
Ihre Nachname lautet S-C-H-U wie U-Bahn, S-T-E-W-M-R-R.
Jawoll, das ist richtig. Schuster, Paul.
Herr Paul Schuster, spreche ich Ihren Namen richtig aus?
Genau, ja.
Wie alt sind Sie, Herr Schuster?
Wie alt? Ich bin 54.
54 Jahre.
Wie alt sind Sie geboren?
Am 6.08.1979.
6.08.1979.
Genau.
Okay. Wie groß sind Sie, Herr Schuster?
Ich bin 178.
178 und wie viel wiegen Sie so seit?
Ja, ich wiege zu seit nur noch 72 Kilo.
Ich habe irgendwie, ich habe sonst immer 81 gewogen, aber jetzt wiege ich nur noch 72, ja.
Ah, Sie haben 8 Kilo abgenommen?
Ja, ich habe viel abgenommen, ja.
Ich habe keine Gründe, warum ich hier bin, ja.
Ah, okay, verstehe.
Ja, in welchem Zeitraum haben Sie diese Gewicht abgenommen?
Ach, ich wiege mich ja nicht so oft, also vielleicht in einem halben Jahr oder so.
Okay.
Ja, Herr Schuster, was kann ich für Sie tun? Was führt Sie heute so uns?
Ausergewichtsabnahme.
Ja, das ist eine Sache und wissen Sie, ich habe so ein komisches Gefühl im Hals.
Ich habe beim Schlucken so beschwerden und das tut richtig weh.
Bei festem Essen ist es ganz unangenehm, aber inzwischen kann ich also nicht mal mehr so richtig was Flüssiges zu mir nehmen,
sondern dass das beim Schlucken weh tut.
Das macht mir halt schon so ein bisschen Sorgen und macht mir Angst und ja.
Ja, Ihre Angst ist vollständig, vollständig natürlich.
Sie haben Schluckbeschwerden sowohl beim feste Essen als auch für sich Essen.
Ja, also als das anfing, als das anfing, das ist schon jetzt ja vielleicht schon 2-3 Monate oder so, ne?
Als das anfing, da habe ich das gemerkt, da habe ich gedacht, ja, hast du nicht gut gekaut oder so.
Und dann tat es beim Schlucken so weh und dann ist das eben immer mehr geworden und inzwischen habe ich das Gefühl,
dass ich also nicht mal mehr kaltes Wasser trinken kann, ohne dass es beim Schlucken weh tut.
Okay, verstehe.
Seit 2 bis 3 Monaten haben Sie diese Beschwerden.
Ja, und das ist immer schlimmer geworden, ja.
Immer schlimmer geworden.
Okay, verstehe.
Haben Sie eine Vergrößerung am Herz bemerkt?
Also eine Vergrößerung, ich habe da nichts bemerkt.
Also, was mir auffällt, dass mir meine ganzen Händen jetzt zu weit sind,
und aber auch meine Hosen, weil ich eben so viel abgenommen habe.
Aber am Hals speziell würde ich sagen, nee, da ist mir nix aufgefallen.
Okay, okay, verstehe.
Aber manchmal habe ich tatsächlich so dieses Gefühl, als ob da etwas wäre,
als ob ich so ein Kloß im Hals hätte.
Okay, Kloßgefühl haben Sie, weiß.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Ich habe mich nicht gemessen, aber eigentlich fühle ich mich nicht fieberig.
Okay, haben Sie vielleicht nach Schweiß oder Schweißausberuhe bemerkt?
Nee, das eigentlich nicht so sehr.
Ich schlafe schlecht, das stimmt, ja.
Also ich wach nachts immer auf oder so,
aber dass ich jetzt irgendwie nachts schwitze oder so, ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Okay, aber Sie schlafen nicht gut?
Ich schlafe nicht gut, nein.
Darf ich fragen, warum schlafen Sie nicht gut?
Vielleicht müssen Sie auf die Toilette gehen, oder haben Sie noch andere?
Nein, ich würde sagen, kann ich nicht erkennen, warum ich nicht gut durchschlafen kann.
Aber jedenfalls wache ich oft nachts auf und dann kann ich nicht gut wieder einschlafen.
Okay, Sie haben keine bestimmte Ursache bemerkt.
Würde ich jetzt keine, nein.
Okay, okay, verstehe.
Ja, Herr Schuster, haben Sie Hüsten oder haben Sie Luftnot?
Also ich muss morgens manchmal husten und dann kommt so ein bisschen was raus, ja.
Und was ich aber ziemlich häufig habe, dass ich so Luftrennen habe,
das habe ich mir schon extra Kissen ins Bett gelegt, damit es nicht so hoch kommt, ja.
Okay.
Sie haben morgendliche Hüsten und auch so Brinnen und Sie müssen ein paar Kissen benutzen beim Schlafen.
Ja, also ein Zusatz diesen Jahr.
Okay, ein Zusatz.
Kissen benutzen beim Schlafen.
Okay.
Haben Sie ja Ihre Hüsten trocken oder mit Auswurf?
Nee, also morgens kommt da so ein bisschen was raus, ja.
Okay.
Wie sagt der Auswurf aus?
Welche Konsistenz und welche Farbe hat der Auswurf?
Also ich denke mal, das ist so weisslicher Schaum.
Weißlich unschau.
Okay.
Gibt es Bullets im Auswurf?
Haben Sie bemerkt?
Hab ich nicht gesehen.
Aber Sie haben nicht gesehen.
Okay.
Haben Sie Heiserkeit?
Manchmal, wenn das so brennt, so ganz Schlimmes, ja, dann aber eigentlich normalerweise sind
ich unbedingt.
Nicht unbedingt.
Okay.
Ja, Herr Schuster, ich werde Ihnen jetzt ein paar Fragen, so Ihrer allgemeinen Zustand.
Schitelle.
Ja, Sie haben uns schon gesagt, seit sechs Monaten haben Sie ungefähr acht
Kilo abgedacht.
Ja.
Ich vermute, dass Sie keine guten Appetit haben.
Nein, es schmeckt mir eigentlich schon lange Zeit überhaupt gar nicht, ja.
Und dazu kommt jetzt eben auch noch, also einmal habe ich keinen Appetit und dann
tut mir jetzt das Schlucken weh und dann mag man natürlich gar nicht mehr essen.
Okay, keinen Appetit.
Und auch seit sechs Monaten haben Sie Appetitlosigkeit.
Ja, wann schwingt das an?
Also, ja, also ich habe das so aufs Alter geschwommen, ja, man braucht nicht mehr so viel
oder so, aber ja, also ich, ich glaube, ich vielleicht auch schon länger, ich kann es
gar nicht genau sagen.
Okay, verstehe.
Ja, Sie haben schon Gewicht abgenommen, aber haben Sie besonders gemacht oder ist
ja, essen Gewohnheit in letzter Zeit geandert?
Nein, also wenn man davon absieht, dass ich jetzt in letzter Zeit eben nicht mehr so
gerne Brot esse oder so, weil es so trocken dann so weh tut im Hals, aber
sonst habe ich mich eigentlich, so esse ich genauso wie vorher auch.
Okay, Sie haben keine Veränderung.
Also ich habe es nicht dramatisch irgendwie verändert an meinen Essgewohnheiten.
Okay, okay, verstehe.
Haben Sie Übelkeit oder haben Sie schon ein Bruch?
Nee, das muss ich zum Glück nicht.
Wie ist es mit dem Stullgang?
Es ist alles in Ordnung?
Ja, eigentlich kann ich normal auf die Stullläfte gehen, ja.
Okay.
Welche Farbe hat der Stull?
Na ja, je nachdem, was man gegessen hat, also der ist braun halt in verschiedenen Farben, ja.
Okay, gibt es Blut im Stull?
Haben Sie bemerkt?
Nee, aber nee, das hätte ich doch gesehen.
Nee, nee, da ist nichts Blutiges.
Das ist eine gute Zeichen.
Okay, haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlösen?
Nee, noch nicht sagen wir mal, irgendwann kommt es ja, aber nee, bisher geht das eigentlich.
Okay, kein Problem.
Okay, super, das freu ich mich.
Ja, leiden Sie unter Brustschmerzen oder Herzrasen oder Engelgefühl?
Nein, nein, ich glaube, mit dem Herzen hat das nichts zu tun.
Nein, das ist mehr so hier oben im Hals.
Ja, verstehe. Okay.
Herr Schuster, jetzt ich werde Ihnen ein paar Fragen so Ihrer Vorgeschichte stellen.
Gibt es chronische Erkrankungen bei Ihnen, von denen ich wissen sollte,
zum Beispiel Blutochterung oder Zuckerkrankheit?
Natürlich habe ich ein bisschen hohen Blutdruck, das haben wir ja alle.
Ja, aber das hat schon vor langer Zeit, schon vor 15 Jahren hat man das festgestellt.
Seit 15 Jahren.
Messen Sie Ihren Blutdruck regelmäßig?
Nee, manchmal, wenn ich zum Hausarzt gehe, dann misst er mal oder, ja,
wenn meine Tochter mich besucht, dann hat sie mal ihr Blutdruckmessgerät dabei,
normalmessig nicht.
Okay. Wann haben Sie das letzte Mal gemessen?
Vor kurzem langer Jahr.
Schon lange her.
Und wissen Sie nicht, wie hoch das ist?
Nein, also ich nehme ja so eine Tablette und dann ist der eigentlich ganz gut.
Okay, super.
Okay, das freut mich. Welche Tablette nehmen Sie regelmäßig gegen Blutdruck?
Nehm ich Metoprolol.
Metoprolol. Kennen Sie Dosieruck?
Oh, das steht da drauf. Also ich nehme da morgens eine Tablette,
aber ich weiß nicht, was da drauf steht.
Okay, das ist nicht schlimm. Ja, aber sehr blutdruck.
Haben Sie noch andere chronische Erkrankungen?
Ne, chronische Erkrankungen, also, was mir halt ein bisschen zu schaffen macht,
ich habe so ein bisschen Krampfadern und bin da auch schon einmal operiert,
weil er hat da auch schon mal eine Thrombose und trage also seitdem Kompressionsschumpe
und ich nehme auch regelmäßig aspirin 100.
Aspirin 100. Okay.
Ja, außer dieser Operation, hatten Sie noch andere Operationen?
Ne, ich bin überhaupt noch nicht operiert worden, die Thrombose ist auch nicht operiert worden.
Dann habe ich falsch verstanden.
Wegen Krampfader wurden Sie nicht operiert.
Ne, da trage ich nur Kompressionsschumpe.
Okay, haben Sie bisher keine Operationen?
Ne, nee, nee.
Okay, jetzt verstehe ich.
Kann sein, dass ich das falsch gesagt habe eben, ja.
Okay. Ja, außer Metaprolol und aspirin, nehmen Sie noch andere Medikamente?
Ne, sonst nehme ich nichts.
Okay, sind Sie allergisch gegen etwa Polen, Hauptstopp oder bestimmte Medikamente?
Sobald ich mich erinnern kann, gibt es bei mir keine Allergie, nee.
Keine Allergie, ja.
Ich kann alles vertragen.
Okay, Sie vertragen alle Nahrungsmittel mit Guletanfos.
Auch Nahrungsmittel, ja.
Ja, ich mag nicht alles, aber ich vertrag alles, ja.
Ja, super, das freut mich. Darf ich fragen, ob Sie rauchen?
Ja, natürlich schon seit ewigen Zeiten, seit 30 Jahren rauche ich schon
und es kann ich mir auch nicht abgewöhnen und ich auch auch ganz schön viel,
das sind so eineinhalb Schachtel am Tag, ja.
Ein- und halb Schachtel.
Und seit 30 Jahren rauchen Sie.
Ja.
Ja, aber aus medizinischer Sicht ist der tägliche Nikotinkonsum so viel.
Haben Sie schon versucht, mit dem rauchen aufzuhören?
Mein Hausarzt berätet mich da auch immer und aber ich, ah, jetzt bin ich so alt geworden.
Jetzt ist es schwer vom Nikotin wegzukommen, ja.
Ja, Sie haben vollkommen recht, das ist nicht einfach,
aber wenn Sie möchten, kann ich Ihnen gerne ein Spezialisten empfehlen.
Jetzt muss ich erst mal hier mein Problem los werden, da.
Okay, okay.
Sie möchten so erst auf Ihre aktuellen Beschwerden konzentrieren.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, also Bier zählt ja nicht so richtig als Alkohol, ne.
Also ich trinke schon ein paar Flaschen Bier am Abend
und ja, so hin und wieder gibt es auch ein Schnaps, also ein paar Mal in der Woche so, ne.
Sie trinken ein, zwei Flaschen Bier und ein...
Ja, eher zwei, drei, würde ich sagen, ja.
Ein, zwei, drei.
Jede Abend.
So gut wie ja, doch, jeden Abend ja.
Wie viel trinken Sie Schnaps, jeder Abend?
Jeden Abend nicht, aber wenn nicht, dann trinke ich mal so dreifiche Schnäpsel,
wenn es etwas zu feiern gibt oder so unter der Woche mal so einen dazu, ja.
Okay, ja, darf ich fragen, seit wann Sie diese Menge Alkohol trinken?
So als Erwachsener fängt man halt an, ne, irgendwann, ja.
Seit 18. Lebensjahr, ungefähr.
Ja, oder 20. Ja.
Okay, verstehe.
Und wie viel Mililiter ist eine Flasche für Bier, meine?
Das ist immer so eine halbe Liter.
Halbe Liter.
Das ist auch ein bisschen viel, ja.
Ja, das sagt mein Hausnachtler auch immer, deswegen gehe ich da auch nicht so gerne hin, ja.
Ja, ich verstehe. Okay.
Ja, bitte nehmen Sie mir die nächste Frage nicht über, das ist eine Routinefrage.
Nehmen Sie irgendwarte Droge?
Ne, das nur nicht auch noch, nee, also mit Zigaretten und Alkohol, das reicht, ja.
Ja, das freut mich, ja.
Sind Ihre Eltern gesucht oder wer hat Krankheit, gibt es Ihre Eltern?
Also, meine Mutter hat genau wie ich auch,
Trumpf alle in den Beinen, ganz schlimm. Hallo.
Und mein Vater, der hatte einen Schlaganfall und ist seitdem also sehr eingeschränkt, ja, und pflegebedürftig.
Das tut mir leid.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ja, einen Bruder habe ich, ja.
Ist er gesund?
Nicht wirklich, also, der hatte eine ganz duve Krebserkrankung,
irgendwas so mit der Bauchspeichodrüse und der ist überhaupt nicht alt geworden, der ist ganz früh verstorben.
Ja, das tut mir leid für Ihre Eltern.
Darf ich fragen, wie alt er ist, wenn er gestorben ist?
Der war, also, schon 50?
Ja, er war sehr jung, ja.
Jetzt, ich werde Ihnen ein paar Fragen zur sozialen Statue stellen, herrschüster.
Was ist Ihr von Beruf?
Ich bin Angestellter bei der Handwächskammer.
Handwächskammer.
Ja, ich habe da so ein Job als Angestellter, so kleine Arbeiten, ja.
Angestellter Handwächskammer, ja.
Okay, und Sie arbeiten im Büro, habe ich richtig verstanden?
Ja, oftmals im Büro, aber manchmal auch, wenn irgendwas sonst zu erledigen ist,
wenn Botengänge zu machen sind oder so, dann mache ich das auch.
Okay, okay.
Sie sind sehr verheiratet.
Nicht mehr, ich bin geschieden.
Ich bin geschieden.
Wie viele Kinder?
Ja, also die sind aber natürlich schon erwachsen, ne?
Ja, natürlich.
Wie viele Kinder haben Sie?
Zwei.
Ist sie gesund?
Die sind gesund, ja, ja, ja.
Haben Sie Stress im Privatleben oder bei der Arbeit?
Ja, ein bisschen Stress hat man natürlich immer, aber im Augenblick
stresst mich, glaube ich, meine Schmerzen stressen mich am meisten, ja.
Ja, ich verstehe. Okay, Herr Schuster, wir sind jetzt mit dem Gespräch fertig.
Ich werde so als eine Köpferle unter so Hunk machen,
danach Blut für das Lebe aufnehmen.
Und auch wahrscheinlich eine Magenspiegelung durchführen.
Muss ich dafür im Krankenhaus bleiben?
Ja, jetzt kann ich nicht genau sagen, aber wahrscheinlich
sollen Sie im Krankenhaus bleiben, damit wir Ihre Situation schnell reagieren können.
Ja, so erst besprechen ich Ihre Situation mit meinem Opa-Arzt,
dann komme ich zu Ihnen, eckere Ihnen alles Schritt für Schritt.
Das stimmt gut, ja.
Gut, danke schön.
Gerne, dann warten Sie hier, ich komme gleich.
Super, ja, danke.
Hat jemand noch Fragen, unser Patient?
Guten Tag, mein Name ist Sumera Firat.
Heute habe ich einen neuen Patient aufgenommen, darf ich vorstellen?
Ja, natürlich, wie haben Sie gesehen?
Es geht um Herr Paul Schuster.
Er ist 54 Jahre alt und am 16.08.1979 geboren.
Er ist 1 Meter, 78 kroos und wiegt 72 Kilogramm.
Er stellt sich bei uns wegen seit zwei bis drei Monaten bestehenden Disfagi vor.
Laut Aussagen des Patienten hat er Disfagi sowohl beim festen Nahrungsmittel
als auch flüssiger Nahrungsmittel.
Er berichtet, dass er ungefähr in den 6 Monaten in Eral 8 Kilogramm Gewicht abgelommen.
Er begleitet, er überlegt,
er hat morgen die Tussier mit weißen, schäumigen Auswurf
und Pioris, ja, und manchmal Heiserkeit.
Er begleitet sich in der Patience, ja, nur in der Patience.
Bei der Feuerkranken-Anamnese erwähnt er Artillerie-Hypertone seit 15 Jahren.
Er hat eine Erweiterung von Metaprolol in unklare Dosis, einmal morgens,
und Komplexstöpfe, Anwände von Komplexstöpfe
und Aspirin, 100 Milligramm, einmal morgens.
Eine allergenen Anamnese war Unafeli, die Noxen-Anamnese ergab,
ja, einen Moment bitte,
circa 5,40 Packiers und 2 bis 3 Flasche Biya,
täglich und manchmal extra Schnaps,
und seit ungefähr 35 Jahren.
Die Familien-Anamnese ergab Krampfader oder Varikose
bei der Mutter, Apoplex, beim Vater und Pankreas Karcinom,
beim Bruder und daran gestorben.
Sozial-Anamnestisch ist eher angestärkt beim Handwerk,
und eher ist geschieden, hat zwei Kinder und sie sind gesund.
Die Anamnestischen Angaben deuten am 1. auf Josef Fagus Karcinom,
Gewichtsabnahme und Disfage beim festen Nahrungsmittel
und für Lösungsmittel und Heiserkeit, Sortbränen,
Sprachen dafür.
Das Gerbe ist den Differentialdiagnostisch noch für Ideen.
Die Differentialdiagnostisch kommen,
die Gastroesophage, Reflexkrankheit und Lungenkarcinom im Betracht.
Okay, oder was noch?
Akalasia vielleicht.
Ja, genau, sehr gut.
So weiter in Abklärung werde ich so als Körperle-Untersuchung
vornehmen, die Vitalparamette überprüfen
und Blut für das Label abnehmen.
Natürlich ein EKG schreiben im Labor.
Worauf achten Sie denn bei der körperlichen Untersuchung
vom Aspekt her?
Ja, bei der Körperle-Untersuchung achte ich auch,
natürlich Allgemeinsustand und ob es eine Größerung
im Armhals vorhanden ist.
Und das noch?
Es ist eine Blase und natürlich Vergrößerung der Lymphknoten.
Der Lymphknoten, ja wohl, ja.
Im Labor werde ich Blutbild,
Entzündung, Parameter, Nierenwerte, Leberwerte, Elektrolytewerte
bestimmen lassen.
Als Apparativ werde ich eine
Özophage-Gastro-Diodenoscope durchführen.
Natürlich werde ich ein Konsul in der
Hyrurgie antworten.
Sollte sich meine Verdachtdiagnose bestätigen,
sollte der Patienten stationär aufgenommen werden,
damit wir alle wichtige Untersuchungen
durchführen können.
Welche Untersuchungen wären denn da wichtig noch?
Wenn unsere Diagnose feststeht?
Natürlich, Biopsy.
Auch, ja.
Und das noch?
Das noch.
Können Sie mir helfen?
Momentan.
Ob es irgendwie metastas...
Natürlich, um, ja, Sie haben recht,
um metastas so rechechieren.
Und wir auf jeden Fall City,
Torax-Abdomen, durchführen.
Gegebenenfalls vielleicht ein Pet City durchführen.
Ja, sehr gut, okay.
Ja, natürlich, der Patient braucht eine...
je nach Befunde wird eine Operation.
Oder Operation und Chemotherapie,
Radiotherapie,
erforderlich, ja.
Ja, sehr gut, ja.
Gut, ja, dann klingt ja nicht gut für den Patienten.
Halten Sie mich auf dem Laufenden,
was Ihre Ergebnisse sind.
Und dann schauen wir mal,
wie es dem Herrn Schuster
nach den ganzen Untersuchungen geht.
Ja, irgendwas, was wir für Befunde haben.
Halten Sie mich, wie gesagt, auf dem Laufenden, ja.
Gut.
Okay.
Ja, ich denke mal, Sie haben wieder
eine sehr schöne Anamnese gemacht,
haben auch einen sehr schönen Bericht gemacht.
Wirklich,
wieder mal jemand, der sehr entspannt
in seine Prüfung gehen kann, würde ich sagen, ja.
Ja, Prüfung.
Ja, natürlich, Sie machen das sehr souverän.
Sie sind sehr nett,
Sie sind sehr nett zum Patienten
und gehen schön auf das ein,
was er gesagt hat.
Hier gucken Sie mal, was Sie Applaus trinken, Wahnsinn.
Ja.
Und ich habe das gemerkt,
Sie haben sich mal so ein bisschen korrigiert.
Zum nächsten Mal haben Sie gesagt,
haben Sie, haben Sie,
ist Ihnen aufgefallen,
haben Sie noch stehen geholfen?
Ja, für Sie haben Sie mich gewalt.
Bitte sagen Sie.
Ja, aber Sie haben, Sie haben mich sehr elegant rausgezogen,
wobei Sie tatsächlich ein bisschen sprachlich,
ein bisschen sicherer sind in der,
in der Anamnese,
in der,
in dem Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch,
also minimale Formulierungsgeschichten,
aber eigentlich so gut wie nicht, muss man sagen.
Das war schon verfliegst gut, ja.
Und mir hat nur eine einzige Sache,
ist mir aufgefallen, also rein inhaltlich.
Er hat ja nicht nur gesagt,
dass er Krampf anhand hat,
sondern er hat auch gesagt,
dass er eine Trompose hatte, eine TVT.
Und dass er deswegen aspirin nimmt.
Aber dann habe ich falsch verstanden.
Ich habe verstanden,
dass er eine Krampfader hat,
danach entsteht eine Trompose.
Ja?
Ja, ich habe Solhe verstanden.
Aber habe ich nicht gedacht,
dass ich falsch verstanden habe.
Deswegen habe ich nicht gedacht.
Nein, das ist ja auch nicht falsch.
Die Trompose kommt ja im Zusammenhang mit der Krampfader, natürlich.
Aber deswegen trägt er Kompressions-Trumpen
als ASS.
Normalerweise, wenn er keine Trompose gehabt hätte,
hätte er ja keinen ASS bekommen.
Ja, natürlich.
Das ist das Einzige.
Aber sonst haben sie sich brillant geschlagen.
Natürlich wird der Patient ein bisschen unwillig.
Der geht ja nicht zu seinem Hausast.
Weil der mir immer sagt,
sie rauchen zu viel, sie trinken zu viel.
Und wenn sie ihm dann im Gespräch jetzt sagen,
mit dem Alkohol, das ist schon ein bisschen viel
und so viele Zigaretten wollen sie nicht lieber aufhören,
dann will er das natürlich nicht so gerne hören.
Das ist so eine Geschichte,
sage ich aber eigentlich immer,
wenn das angesprochen wird.
Die Patienten hören das nicht so gerne.
Reagieren dann vielleicht ein bisschen ungehalten.
Jetzt fällt mir gerade ein,
dass ich glaube ich eine Sache haben sie auch nicht gefragt.
Und zwar die Schmerzintensität haben sie tatsächlich nicht abgefragt.
Ja, ich habe nicht gefragt.
Wobei das glaube ich auch tatsächlich nicht das Relevante ist.
Denn der beschreibt ja weniger die Schmerzen
als dieses unangenehme Gefühl.
Und da sind sie wahrscheinlich gar nicht so in die Schmerzrichtung
abgebogen, aber in diesem Fallbeispiel gibt es halt eine Schmerzanlage.
Und ja, ich glaube es ist schon so,
wenn da jemand wirklich ein Tumor in der Speiseröhre hat,
dass dem das schon auch richtig wehtut, wenn er schluckt.
Ja, Sie haben das total vergessen,
ich habe nur auf das Fajé Konzert.
Ja, ja, ja.
Gut, aber ansonsten, ich muss sagen, ich fand das auf alle Fälle sprachlich,
sehr souverän und haben sie gut gemacht, wirklich.
Vielen Dank für Ihre Unterstützung
und vielen Dank, Sie motiviert mich.
Ich werden Ihnen die Daumen am 2.2. natürlich, ja.
Aber vorher sehen wir uns vielleicht nochmal,
Dienstag, ja, Dienstag könnten wir uns wieder treffen,
wenn es Ihnen recht ist.
Dann bin ich zu Hause, dann auch wieder um 8 Uhr.
Okay, ja, das freue ich mich.
Dann möchte ich nicht andere Freunde oder Freunde brauchen,
dann natürlich möchte ich mit Ihnen wieder einer.
Ja, wir gucken mal, wer ausgewählt wird,
das entscheiden ja die Herren, ja, Dr. Pupil, Dr. Gündes.
Gut, ja, für heute verabschiede ich mich,
wünsche Ihnen allen einen guten Abend
und dann ein gutes Wochenende, wenn es soweit ist
und erst mal schön Dank,
dass Sie sich zur Späterstunde noch darauf eingelassen haben.
Tschüss.
Frau Gelt, wenn Sie seithaben und ich würde gerne auch etwas sagen.
Ja, gerne.
Ich bin Sahit aus Dresden.
Wir haben in der Vergangenheit mehr mal Simulationen durchgeführt.
Ich habe auch vorgestern die Prüfung geschafft.
Sie sind das, ja, super.
Ich habe mich schon gewundert, ja, ich habe das Gesicht kennst du.
Ja, wunderbar, herzlichen Glückwunsch.
Danke schön.
Ich bedanke Ihnen tatsächlich für alle Simulationen,
nicht nur meine Simulationen.
Vor der Prüfung habe ich auch die alle Simulationen
von Ihnen schon mehrmals gehört und wiederholzt.
Und Sie auch nicht mehr hören wahrscheinlich.
Sie schon wieder.
Ja, Sie sehen tatsächlich aus, als ob Sie erkältet wären.
Ja, bin ich auch.
Deswegen guter, besser.
Dankeschön.
Und verraten Sie uns nochmal eben schnell.
Was war Ihr Fall?
Ach so, das war für mich ein neuen Fall.
Es war nicht ein gewöhnliche Fall.
Ich denke, ich habe auch während der Prüfung die Diagnose nicht gestellt.
Ja, okay.
Ja, es war ganz neu.
Es war ein dermatologischer Fall.
Das war aber sehr exotisch, oder?
Ja, es war für mich tatsächlich so.
Das finde ich aber sehr schwer.
Ja, und was war das?
Ich habe auch meinen Kollegen gefragt.
Sie haben gesagt, es kann auch Basellium sein
oder Saborerische Dermatitis sein.
Aber es kann auch Psyriasis sein.
Wir wissen auch jetzt nicht.
Aber das finde ich ja extrem schwierig.
Das ist doch ein absolutes Facharzt-Thema.
Also das ist doch völlig blöde, so etwas in der Prüfung zu fragen.
Und beim ASAS haben mir auch, oder wurde mir auch die Diagnose nicht gefragt.
Nur die Informationen von Patienten.
Ach, okay.
Ich habe viele Fragen bekommen.
Prüfung war schwer.
Ja.
Das ist schön.
Ja, gut.
Aber das ist ja cool.
Ich freue mich sehr, dass ihr bestandene habt.
Wie allen kann ich immer nur viel Geduld und gute Nerven wünschen
bei den weiteren Schritten,
bis sie endlich an der richtigen Stelle sind, wo sie arbeiten können.
Vielen Dank.
Ich denke, ich kann hier für meine Kollegen etwas sagen.
Tatsächlich, es ist große Bedeutung für uns, was Sie hier machen.
Ich danke Ihnen auch noch mal.
Ja, vielen, vielen Dank.
Ja, und ich mache es gerne.
Das merken Sie wahrscheinlich.
Und es tut mir immer leid, wenn ich absagen muss,
weil wieder hier irgendwas ist.
Aber schön, dass wir uns heute sehen konnten.
Und danke, dass Sie gekommen sind.
Ich freue mich sehr.
Also noch einmal Tschüss allen zusammen.
Schönen Abend.
Danke.